what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video by mediocre
tutorials and reviews um it's a response
video to a video that he made so it's
called i am the prototype
mike rasheed responds to my video while
discussing the problem with red pill
men before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers and each and every one of
you helps me get to that goal
while you're at it ring that
notification belly that way you're going
to be notified
of my daily videos okay
i'm like new to this guy's channel i
haven't seen a ton of it but
it'll be interesting to hear this dial
[Music]
all right guys listen you looking at the
thumbnail you're looking at the title of
the video you already know what time it
is it is time
to get active
got a response so guys we must
go over it shout out again to mike
rashid
i did a video not too long ago let's
just go down in there
i did a video not too long ago entitled
mike rashid disrespects the red pill
after attending the fresh and fit
podcast
let's get active
guys i'll be honest most of the times i
do videos i don't expect the people
that the video is about to see the video
but mike saw the video
and he was actually down into my comment
section
not replying to me but replying to other
people's comments in the comment section
what i thought was particularly
interesting because i i i saw him not in
and i was thinking to myself
well what does he think about the video
because he's just responding to other
people
so he recently was back on his podcast
and
the topic of the video came up so let's
review that
without further ado i move how i want to
move and i
answer to my own rules yeah i create my
own rules
they're mad at me for not subscribing to
the rules that somebody else wrote
i don't care yeah i don't even know it
all and i don't want to know
they they got a kick out of saying well
he doesn't even know the whole thing
about
and i don't want to know i i have no i
don't have enough space in my brain
for that i got other [ __ ] i'm trying to
challenge somebody to say
okay so okay there's a there's a
subscribe notion
to this indoctrinated way of thinking
and what the [ __ ]
i hate when people say the word
indoctrinated it's not really
indoctrinated
it's just like a different belief
systems than you have
like i've heard people say that and like
like i've heard
people from every like
a lot of different groups say that about
a different group and it doesn't even
mean that
like someone's indoctrinated it really
just means that they have a different
way of thinking than you
does it get you um it gets you an
understanding
of uh the um
actual intentions of people behind the
curtains
it gets you an understanding of the
things that you should be focused on
within your life in order to excel to be
the best
version of yourself it also gets you
the understanding of signing your name
on the dotted line and
what are all of the negative things and
the impacts of if you sign your name on
that marriage contract knowing that
there's a 50
divorce rate 70 percent of which is
initiated by women
and then what is generally the outcome
of the person that is the breadwinner
so i would say it's an enhance of
knowledge it's an enhance of
um philosophy um and as well as a
enhance of manhood okay
just just just to name a few but let's
keep going
here's the thing all it does is make you
mad i actually don't
disagree with that i think there's a lot
of like positive stuff
for like guys where they talk about like
how to get in shape for fitness how to
enhance like your career goals
um so i definitely see what he's saying
i agree
no doesn't these guys in the comments
are mad right
and then let me address that as well um
just briefly because i talked about the
red pill rage
um before there's a lot of young men
that would be mad
without understanding the content of
what
red pill is there's a lot of young men
that are still
mad anyway now i will say
that a lot of the content there are men
that use it to
validate their own existence or they
look at content
that um points a finger at
women contributing badly to society as a
way to
affirm their perception of
women in general and in mass and if they
do not take a holistic view of the
content that they're
consuming then they can stay within that
rage
and stay within their for a long period
of time because
i think like at the end of the day
having a
platform that affirms
uh your thoughts your experiences can be
as
addicting as heroine okay
and from a content creator's perspective
you know
depending upon how it is that we choose
to deal with our platform
we can continue to hand out these
medicine tablets day in
and day out to continue to feed
the masses so i get what your point is
but i think that it's coming from much
more of a perspective of just not
understanding and i think that's a bit
no no look at
i watch a lot of the red pill i
understand like what they're talking
about but there's a lot of guys in red
pill
that i understand what they're talking
about but they just genuinely don't like
women
like they always talk about how like
modern
women like can't be wives modern women
this modern woman that but it's like
it's like the women that you choose to
date
that like do you like that you don't
have to date them the basis of human
evolution
because we don't all have the
opportunity to be able to understand it
so if we're hit by an opposing force
we're going to resist and i think a
component of that resisting
happened to mike and i think as
melissa ford is talking about this it's
happening to her as well but besides her
defending her her co-host but anyway
let's keep going
mad at me and they're trying to belittle
me because their whole thing is
they have this idea about you it's
understanding women right
and they're saying i seen today um it
was a brother
i can't remember the name of his uh his
podcast
excuse me my bro it's all good bro i
actually like your podcast
it's a long weird name i know [ __ ] was
the name of his show he was a black kid
and you know he just spoke about it and
a little click baity
it seemed like we were going at it
because the picture looked all crazy and
[ __ ] but
he was very reasonable called a great
assessment of a video that shawn and i
did talking about
red pill what women really like whatever
so
but the comments was just silly right
and it's like
these guys in the comments they're
talking about
well red pill is all about understanding
what women want now one thing the guy
said
and then they all adopted what he said
they said
well mike you never have problems with
girls but look at you like you're a
genetic specimen
you're successful yadda yadda i'm like
hold tight hold the phone real quick
i was skinny as [ __ ] growing up my
nickname was skinny right
me too i was one i left high school at 1
30
right i left that one when i was about
i stopped fighting for the first time i
think i was 23 i was 158 pounds
right i didn't even get close to 200
pounds
until i was 31 32. oh wow i was a thin
guy all my life right
but my confidence was this big right and
i didn't have money on my life
and they also said you know he he he's a
good looking guy with a great physique
and he makes millions of dollars off of
that yeah like i stopped no
i make money with this right here
there's plenty of people
in my industry that look better than me
more physically attractive than me
better physiques
all of that they don't make any money
and they're trying you know what i'm
saying
plenty of guys swole all of that don't
they can't get a girl
to save their lives you know what i'm
saying so and i made money before this
you know i'm saying so i've always put
myself in a position of leadership with
this
has nothing to do with how i look now no
i actually agree with that there are
some people that are just
naturally like gift like they have the
gift of gab
almost like they're just really good at
talking to people and like they've
always had that from just a young age
it's not really something that can be
how i look let's talk about that
so just real quick so um
very fair points brother so here's the
thing is that like
um so he was talking about his size and
i did a quick google search to make sure
how tall that is that came up was 511.
this was on google i'm not sure how
fair that is uh but it says 5.11 so
leaving high school at about 511
130 that is really skinny i left high
school at about 150 155 pounds
but i left at about 6162. similar to you
i was always labeled skinny i hated
being labeled skinny so
i made sure that you know when i got
into a place where i can work out the
way that i needed to work out i learned
everything that i could
to become the best body version of
myself but what i thought was really
important of what he was talking
right here is that he stuck on this and
i love that he said that and brought
that up because you know previous to
this i wasn't
you know you look at him and you assume
he looked like that his entire life but
what he's saying that is that he
differentiated himself by
using key things within his personality
to become
the best the brightest the strongest or
what have you and leverage those things
to eke out the competition over time
from a leadership perspective now again
we're tossing the
red pill stuff to the side for a quick
second and i appreciate that message
because that's an important message even
within myself i say
you know if i look back on my very short
youtube stint and career like what are
the components that i have been
utilizing to leverage to
get farther into my future right farther
down this
roadway in this path and i give you the
same answer as well
it is consistent honing consistent
discipline consistent
learning that it helps me excel to the
next stage
but let's get back to his thoughts real
quick because i want to hear more before
i give you the rest of my thoughts
to boxing at an early age i wanted to be
strong i wanted to be
a capable man right um and as i got
older and older i just wanted to always
be capable and
able to protect and yada yada all that
[ __ ] right
so training and
the way i look from training and the
confidence that i carry from training
and my self-estimation is high all that
[ __ ]
because of things that i'm doing to
qualify myself to be a dope-ass
man for a woman right these are not i
wasn't born with these attributes
these are decisions that i made right in
my life
to qualify myself to be that
[ __ ]
but this is what i mean like
i feel like with like
certain things like guys have it easier
like i feel like guys can at least like
improve with the cards they're given i
don't think girls can as much
okay um what i thought was interesting
that he said that i think he corrected
uh in the future is that he said to
qualify himself for a woman
i thought that was interesting because
to hear all the things that he put
himself through
right to know how he's grown as an
individual right like as a person
to know that he's done combat sports to
that degree and i think he's a boxer
right now
and by the way like you know if i ever
have sons
that's the first thing that i'm going to
make sure that they get into
long and often i i did martial arts as a
kid as well and i
and there's nothing like the um pure
discipline that is within your soul and
your spirit like to understand how to
push yourself to the brink and back
again
nothing oh my gosh i did karate for like
a week and it was the worst week of my
life
that takes so much discipline oh my gosh
that is not funny then more i don't
think there's no other sport that does
it
like combat sports not football not
basketball and i say that because those
are team sports
but 101 mano e mano there's nothing
like combat sports to really hone your
mind at what it takes to be successful
with something
but what i found interesting is that he
said that he did all these things to
qualify himself for
a woman and that surprised me he then
corrected it later
and then said uh qualified him to be a
leader but i tell you guys
all day is do not do things for women
okay that's just the icing on the cake
okay
after you work in and develop yourself
into the leader that you claim that you
want to be
the best at what it is that you do the
best in your industry the best
in your school right no that's actually
really good advice
there's like nothing more unattractive
than a guy that's like just doing things
like clearly
just like for girls i don't know i do
not
because you can just like spot it i
don't know how to describe it do it for
you we're talking okay go ahead so these
guys they gotta understand
they're not going to come in right when
we started like um
like dating right
you never did anything like to just
impress me
like you were just doing you nothing
yeah and that's why i like liked you was
because you were like
doing your own thing you know you're
just like
and you're funny
where are you going
they're saying it's not fair this is it
no no this is the issue you're trying to
make logic out of crazy that's that's
your problem right now
is you're talking about i hate that's
the worst argument oh my gosh that's the
worst argument
i don't even agree with everything in
red pill but if you're just gonna
call them like crazy like you have to
talk about what points are crazy
like which what points not just the
whole move a couple people
stop it i'm trying to give something
stop it no no no no i'm trying to give
perspective and the perspective is this
i'm black right mm-hmm i wasn't born
with a [ __ ] silver spoon i was born
in a gutter in brooklyn
when brooklyn was real brooklyn rats
bigger than cats
that's where i come from the best style
anybody from brooklyn
know what i'm talking about cocaine 80s
right i'm from that [ __ ]
right my house that i lived in corrupted
our whole block
right like my life was a movie a bad
movie
a horrible movie right but guess what
i'm still here right
so so what i'm saying though is this
instead of looking at somebody like me
oh well you're just privileged or you
look like no [ __ ]
i work my ass off for everything that i
got and i'm still planting seeds
still right do the same [ __ ] thing
don't don't come at somebody like me oh
you only got girls because
okay yeah that's why i got girls but
listen there's fat because one guy was
like well
there's plenty of guys with nice
personalities that don't have the looks
that people are overlooking if he was
rich he'd have all the [ __ ]
there's plenty of unattractive
[ __ ] with the bag
that gets what they want that's a that's
that's a real
real vibe so if you don't have the looks
get the money
and you got the girl yeah there's no
[ __ ] excuse your shortcomings
with women is because of you not because
of women
you know what's so okay uh let's address
a couple of those points do you guys
agree with that
because that's like that sounded really
true to me
i don't know like
he's right there really aren't a lot of
experience uh one of the things that he
said
is that because of his current
aesthetics is the reason why he doesn't
get it and i'd argue like this is that
like
yeah but that's still true though to a
degree and it just depends again
i don't know what he said on the fresh
and fit podcast or what have you
however uh where you are genetically
right now does shield you from what the
average man deals with
okay it shields you i'd love to know
more about
how he conducted himself when he was
coming out of high school
130 pounds okay because maybe because
here's the thing
there's those of us that get red pill
without looking out content on the
internet so
like for me for example i had a
situation or two
or three that happened to me in my early
20s
which put me on a path in a road like
you my g
you understand what i'm saying so my
path didn't involve
the aesthetics of my body although i
love to work out
and involved working on this wholly and
truly within white collar sector
so i naturally came across it i'd argue
that you naturally came across it as
well it just manifested itself
differently
i think that like what happened is is
that he just put the cart before the
horse he worked on himself he worked on
his body
with his discipline and created a path
for himself
that has been extremely lucrative right
so now he doesn't have to come about
the same situations within life with the
modern woman
as the average dude the average modern
dude he doesn't see it like that
because he doesn't need to because now
he's ascended to a place where
he is now a valuable dude he is a yeah i
mean if his whole point
is this guy's rich and he doesn't
understand average people
i mean duh duh i value dude but i
absolutely agree with him when he says
that every chick that you lost was
because of
you i absolutely believe that because at
the end of the day
you now have the information to
understand how the modern woman
acts how they will treat you strategies
and perspectives in order to
increase the likelihood of success but
at the end of the day if you continue to
choose women that are out your league
if you continue to choose women that are
toxic in nature and you're getting butt
hurt and upset about that
well that's nobody else's fault well
that's what irritates me about the red
pill is like there's so many guys
that they pick the toxic it's the same
girls do the same thing but they'll pick
like the toxic girls and then complain
it's like you you picked them you didn't
have to date them
like i mean girls do the exact same
thing like i say the same thing when
girls say like men are trash but like
yeah that's one thing that irritates me
sometimes but you
i also want to judge melissa ford
talking about because they're all crazy
and again i think that she's just
hearing her co-host talk about it she
hasn't done research into it and
probably will never do research into it
but oftentimes you hear this perspective
that comes from women as if to say
if anything doesn't boost up a woman
that it must be complete utter [ __ ]
and often times they're not privy to the
information over here
going after topic of topic of complete
and utter anarchy
and out of control didn't this is that a
word within modern
women today but honestly it makes sense
knowing her past knowing her history
knowing that she made money
essentially from male gaze right
the male simp dollar it makes complete
another sense that she wouldn't have
empathy for the average modern man
in understanding the struggles that they
go through
through this crazy world today guys uh
that's my last of my comments i wanted
to make sure to go back in
and talk about that i appreciate his
follow-up thoughts because my assumption
was is that if you look at the young man
he looks like he's been like that isn't
his entire life that's a small brother
that's a okay i think that's the end of
the video um
yeah i agree with a lot of what he is
saying like
i definitely like don't think like red
pill you have to agree with like all
aspects to see like there's some truth
in it but at the same time like
i don't know there's some guys no fat no
offense i love you guys but like some of
you in my comment section
like i don't i don't know what to tell
you but let me know in the comments if
you guys agree
or you disagree um do not forget to
subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell i will talk to you
guys next